hi good morning everyone welcome welcome
thanks to those of you who are here for
the second day who were here also
yesterday Sunday for the first day of
this conference on racism anti-semitism
and the radical right I'm Steve petty
professor of history in American Studies
and ethnicity race and migration and I'm
the director of the Yale Center for the
Study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration I'm Co organizer
of the conference along with my friend
and colleague Maurice aniele's we had a
wonderful day yesterday so I want to
thank everybody for coming out for the
great crowd we had terrific
presentations wonderful questions from
the audience and great engagement during
the break so it was I think a remarkable
day in many respects for those
interested there's also an article in
the Yale Daily News today about
yesterday's events especially if you
missed yesterday and want to know what
happened I'd refer you to the ydn
article if you're interested um today is
gonna be a little bit different one of
the differences today is that it is of
course a school day on the campus so we
will have some students coming in and
out of the building staff and faculty
coming in out of the building so
there'll be a bit more traffic in the
foyer area than we had yesterday so I
just want to alert folks about that and
just ask for your mindfulness knowing
that there are staff members with
offices here in close proximity to where
we are so if you could keep that in mind
that would be helpful we've had some
wonderful engagement between audience
members and panelists yesterday which
were eager to see happen again one
request that I would make of all of us
is when given the opportunity to ask
questions of the panelists it would be
helpful if we all keep our questions
short if we think about trying to limit
those questions to a sentence or two and
not use the opportunity to ask a
question to to go on at length
with one's own perspective that would
allow more questions from the audience
more opportunities for the panelists to
share what they know so if we could keep
that in mind that would be very very
helpful let's see I actually left
something down here I need to grab
a couple of house rules that I wanted to
remind people of today repeating what we
said yesterday I want to remind people
that the Whitney Humanities Center are
wonderful hosts here don't allow eating
or drinking inside of this auditorium so
we they'll ask you to keep that in mind
that the emergency xa exits are located
throughout the hall both here to your
left stage left and also behind you so
please make sure you know where the
emergency exits are we'd ask you all to
please silence your cell phones and to
refrain from using any recording devices
here in the hall
that means audio recording video
recording and photography so please
don't do any of that we asked that any
members of the media please check in
with a representative of the Yale Office
of Public Affairs if you haven't already
done that and you can find somebody to
speak with in the lobby if you fall in
that category restrooms are located of
course outside of the hall on the first
floor and also down in the basement
please contact a staff member out in the
foyer area if you have a difficulty
locating them and finally if you leave
the hall and have a small bag please
take it with you and keep in mind that
it'll be bag checked on the way back in
the final thing I wanted to remind folks
of that we talked about briefly
yesterday is the university's policy on
free expression as I think all of you
know Yale strongly believes in the right
of individuals to express their opinions
but disruption of a university event
isn't consistent with our policies as a
university on free expression so I would
just ask that each person here each
person present respect the right of our
speakers to be heard if a disruption
occurs during the conference today
either Maury or I or another University
official will ask for an end to the
disruptive activity and if the activity
doesn't cease within a reasonable period
of time will repeat the request and we
might have to call on police if
necessary to remove audience members or
help
- in the disruption so we're just out we
just asked people at the baby end of the
day to keep that University policy in
mind and of course respect the
university policy
I'd like now to turn the mic over to our
colleague Adam Stern who will introduce
the panelists and get our day going
thank you very much hi everyone welcome
we are going to start our second day
with a panel on anti-semitism on the
right and we have two speakers with us
Mark Weitzman who is the director of
government affairs for the Simon
Wiesenthal Center he is a member of the
official US delegation to the
international Holocaust Remembrance
Authority where he spearheaded the
adoption of the working definition of
anti-semitism by the 31 member countries
of the ihr a and is a participant in the
program on religion and foreign policy
on the Council of Foreign Relations
among his books are the generic hate our
generic hatred essays in memory of Simon
Wiesenthal which won the 2007 National
Jewish Book Award for best anthology our
second speaker or actually our first
speaker will be David Hirsch who wrote
his PhD at Warwick University on crimes
against humanity and international law
his thesis was published as law against
genocide cosmopolitan trials and it won
the BSA Phillip Abraham's prize for the
best book in sociology his new book out
in August is contemporary left
anti-semitism and today he will be
speaking about what can a study of the
mainstreaming of anti-semitism on the
Left teach us about the new right-wing
populism
thank you mm-hmm thank you very much
this is new for me I'm newly old we are
seeing a polarization in political
discourse on both sides of the Atlantic
the left and the right are coalescing
more and more into political community
which tend to define themselves
primarily in relation to each other
anti-semitism xenophobia sorry
anti-semitic is ana phobic racist and
populist discourses have over the last
two years moved with great speed into
the mainstream in ways that only a
little earlier would have seemed
impossible in Britain the brexit
movement placed the blame for Britain's
key problems on foreigners poles and
Romanians over here taking our jobs and
foreign bureaucrats over there telling
us what to do and denying us our
sovereignty in Britain also we now have
a Labour leadership who's who famously
articulated Jeremy Corbyn famously
articulated his political support for
the anti-semitic movements Hamas and
Hezbollah saying that they were
dedicated to peace and justice and to
the good of the Palestinian people he
has jumped to the defence of Stephen
sizer a man who later asked in public
whether Israel was responsible for 9/11
saying that sizer was being unfairly
smeared by Zionists Corbin had invited
Ryad Sallah a man who had engaged in
many evil style blood libels against
Jews to have tea with him in the House
of Commons saying that Salah was far
from a dangerous man Corbin had worked
for Press TV the Iranian state
propaganda channel and he had endorsed
Russia today as being more reliable than
the mainstream media yesterday we heard
how blood amir Putin's propaganda outlet
employs neo-nazis to D legitimize
democratic discourse and in the United
States as we also heard yesterday
President Trump came to power on a wave
of xenophobic and racist rhetoric
smearing Mexicans as rapists and Muslims
as terrorists his final day campaign
video was identical to classic
anti-semitic conspiracy theory although
it didn't mention Jews it relied on that
disk
course and it functioned as a dog
whistle to those who could understand it
President Trump brought Steve Bannon
into the White House and his
anti-semitism too is not explicit it is
contested and it requires judgment to
identify it Bannon is a man with a long
history of involvement and alliances
with racist and anti-semitic politics
and movements as we also heard yesterday
one of the interesting phenomena we are
seeing at the moment is that people on
the populist right are showing
themselves able to identify with some
sophistication anti-semitism on the left
well people on the populist Left are
showing themselves similarly able to
interpret and decode signs of the
mainstreaming of right-wing
anti-semitism that develops a kind of
competitiveness the real anti-semitism
is over there the right says it's on the
left and is discernible via left-wing
support for Islamist politics and
left-wing tolerance for anti-semitism
within its own ranks the left says that
the real threat comes from right-wing
anti-semitism it says that while the
Nazis themselves at Charlottesville were
bad enough the political support
tolerance and normalization with which
they were greeted by the white house
itself is much more symbolic of the
magnitude of the anti-semitic and racist
threat so long as each is sensitive only
to the anti-semitism of the other but
grete talk of anti-semitism within their
own political family with angry denial
and counter accusation then neither are
really opposing anti-semitism I have a
new book out contemporary left
anti-semitism
it addresses anti-semitism within my own
political family too often anti-semitism
over here is treated as an aberration
amongst friends while anti-semitism over
there is treated as an is sin
manifestation of the rottenness of the
whole discourse in the whole movement my
book is the story of the mainstreaming
of anti-semitism from the Stalinist
periphery of labour and progressive
movements into the mainstream I survey a
few of the key defining characteristics
of this left anti-semitism and then I
will go on to show tentatively how some
of these same characteristics and
structures are also appearing on the
populist right both with respect to
anti-semitism and also with respect to
racism xenophobia and Islamophobia my
book is about an semitism and social
spaces which think of themselves as
anti-racist and democratic it is about
anti-semitism amongst people who believe
that they strongly oppose anti-semitism
this kind of anti-semitism is usually
related to hostility to Israel but it
diverges radically from rational or
legitimate criticism of Israeli policy
while Israelis and Palestinians are real
localized and specific their narratives
are often appropriated blandly
simplified and woven into worldviews
which serve people and purposes far away
the book is interested in the growing
ossification of a tradition of left-wing
thought since the second world war in
Turkey binary opposition's interestingly
we heard this yesterday too
with respect to the popular right the
key binary opposition's in this form of
left-wing thought are black and white
North and South oppressed an oppressor
imperialist anti imperialist 1% 99% the
book shows how the socialist tradition
of supporting self liberation of the
oppressed in each country is in danger
of being surpassed by a new nationalist
tradition of supporting whole nations
which are designated as oppressed
against whole other nations which are
designated as a presser it is a
framework which downplays the importance
of democratic values and practices it is
within this framework that
who could not have been more oppressed
in 1944 can be thought of for short
years later as the bearers of white
European colonialism if Jews are defined
as oppressors and as white then the
assumption that anti-semitism will be
taken seriously in progressive movements
is open to question the book argues that
a politics of position is emerging on
the left in preference to a politics of
reason or persuasion this tends to
solidify an essentialist notion of who
belongs within the community of the
oppressed and the community of the
progressive the boundaries of these
communities are coming more and more to
be policed by coercive discursive
practices and less by democratic debate
and persuasion hostility to Israel can
sometimes become a key marker of
identity in this process if Jews are
reluctant to embrace this hostile to
Israel identity then they risk exile
from what I am calling the community of
the good Jews who are unable or
unwilling publicly to disavow their
relationship to Israel are being made
politically homeless this phenomenon is
being mirrored to some extent on the
populist right whereby support for
Israel which often in fact means support
fully could and for the settler project
tends to be mobilized also as a marker
of membership of that political
community of course there is a long and
menacing history of Christians defining
their identity in relation to Jews and
later to the Jewish Question
as Robert fine and Philip Spencer made
clear in their fantastic new book the
Jew the Jewish Question is always
actually an anti-semitic question but it
is making an unwelcome return to
mainstream discourse people attempted to
ask the David Irving question what is it
that Jews are doing which is leading to
the rise of anti-semitism rather than
the anti-racist question why are Jews
again finding the
selves put into the sensor of political
discourse my book is anchored in
empirical case studies of how
anti-semitism emerges out of the
ostensibly democratic discourses of
criticism of Israel there are lots of
stories in the book stories about things
that have happened things that people
have said and done cultures that have
arisen ways in which people have made
sense of what was going on anti-semitism
is emotional but it often dresses in the
clothes of reason anti-semitism is
something we feel we should be able to
sniff out and to know in an unmediated
way yet this is largely a book about
people who are unable to do so so as
well as the book of stories and emotions
it is also a book of theory and politics
it is it is it is an attempt to
understand a complex and contradictory
reality a world in which people
self-consciousness comes into conflict
with the ways in which other people
interpret them and their actions
methodologically it treats discourse as
being related to the social movements
and cultural spaces within which it
develops this work develops a
sociological understanding of
anti-semitism as an external and
objective social phenomenon rather than
simply as subjective feelings of hatred
or fear within individuals we often see
a slippage in this regard if somebody
says or does something I'd submit it if
somebody embraces or normalizes answers
mythical races politics if somebody has
a record of alliances with anti-semitic
or racist movements their supporters
will often shift the focus from the
action or the politics onto the essence
of the person in the 1980's a certain
kind of anti racism
consciousness-raising was fashionable
people would sit in a circle and the
group would begin like a session of
Alcoholics Anonymous with each person
admitting publicly that they were racist
there was a logic to proceeding in this
way we are human beings we live and are
formed within the existing social world
it is complex and contradictory
so are we it is impossible simply by an
act of the will to cleanse oneself
completely of all the unwanted
assumptions feelings unconscious
motivations and linguistic vocabularies
with that within which we exist if we
begin by admitting that we are not
necessarily immune from racism simply
because we decide to be anti-racist that
it enables us to examine ourselves
honestly without being afraid of
denunciation it is the ones who claim to
be pure who we need to worry about
subjective self consciousness of being
an opponent of anti-semitism it turns
out is no guarantee against stumbling
into anti-semitic ways of thinking
anti-semitism is an objective social
phenomenon because it does not only
reside inside our heads but also in the
cultural spaces in between our heads and
in the relationships between
consciousness culture and material
reality sometimes it is said that
hostility to Israel is a cloak which
hides anti-semitism but this seems to
suggest that people who are
self-consciously anti-semitic are
adopting hostility to Israel as a way of
camouflaging their real underlying to
hating motivations well this may be true
of David Irving for example whose
anti-semitism precedes his criticism of
Israel and so-called but it is more of a
puzzle when people who are aware of no
anti-semitic motivations who think of
themselves as implacable opponents of
anti-semitism act in anti-semitic ways
whether the hostility to Israel comes
first and the anti-semitism follows or
whether the anti-semitism comes first
even if it is unconscious and is a cause
of the disproportionate or irrational or
unique hostility to Israel it is
difficult to know perhaps it makes sense
to understand it as a cycle in which
both anti-semitism and hostility to
Israel feed on each other but in any
case the key issue here is that the
anti-semitism remains steadfastly on
record
and under unacknowledged by the person
who has stumbled into it this is
important if we are to understand the
self righteous anger uncertainty with
which such people reject any suggestion
that what they have said or done is
anti-semitic the indignation is genuine
people look within themselves and find
an absence of Jew hatred they find it
difficult to understand anti-semitism as
an objective social fact preferring to
see it as an individual and mental
internal sentiment having found
themselves not guilty of anti-semitism
they are then tempted to move quickly on
to angrily counter-attacking the motives
of the people who have brought up the
issue the idea that raising the issue of
anti-semitism is a dirty a trick than
anti-semitism itself is occurring to
more and more people independently the
insight is that the debates about
contemporary and semitism itself should
really be recognized as a manifestation
of Zionist ruthlessness and duplicity
this notion widely held does serious
damage to the possibility of considering
anti-semitism in a measured and rational
way either politically or academically
and this lipids from anti-semitism
relating to what we do or say to
anti-semitism relating to the essence of
the person appears on the right as well
as on the left the charge against
President Trump and Steve Bannon is that
they engage in conspiracy theory and
they make alliances with anti-semitic
movements they employ anti-semitic dog
whistles and they legitimize and
tolerate anti-semitism this is why the
response that some of their best friends
are Jewish that President Trump has a
Juris grandchild that Steve Bannon did
or did not want his kids to go to school
with Jews is irrelevant
we have long seen on the Left anti
Zionist Jews mobilizing their Jewish
identity in order to reassure non-jews
that the politics of boycott and
decentralization are quite unrelated to
anti-semite
now we see the COA and Trump supporting
Jews offering similar as a Jew
reassurances for some time we have been
endeavoring to make the point that just
because an idea or an element of
rhetoric appears in anti-zionist
discourse it does not necessarily mean
that it isn't anti-semitic some kinds of
hostility to Israel are of course
anti-semitic while other kinds of
criticism of Israeli policy are of
course entirely legitimate to discern
the difference requires political
judgment but now we're seeing another
reversal having said hostility to Israel
may be anti-semitic now we have to say
so may support for Israel be
anti-semitic my book looks at radical
critiques of Israel and Zionism with a
focus on how they tend to free
themselves from empirical rational or
comparative methodological constraints
anti-zionism began as a critique of a
political movement for national
self-determination after the Holocaust
and the war of 1948 which radically
transformed the material basis of Jewish
life anti-zionism became something quite
new a movement to abolish an existing
nation-state it then matured in some
cases into a world view which
repositioned Jewish wrongdoing at the
center of all that is problematic in the
world the critique of an idea is
different from the critique of an
existing nation-state particular Jewish
concern with Israel and with its
failures takes on a new significance
sometimes when it is exported into the
wider institutions of civil society the
book is grounded in a sociological way
of thinking this helps it step back from
the Israeli and Palestinian nationalist
prisms and representations of them which
emerge far from the conflict debates
concerning anti-semitism are often
distorted by incorporation into
narratives sociology is itself one of
the anti hegemonic discourses which is
vulnerable to anti-semitic ways of
thinking yet I argue also that sociology
provides resources methods and ways of
thinking which can be mobilized for
understanding and then for opposing
anti-semitism anti-semitism is a threat
to Jews but it is also an indicator of a
more profound and general sickness
within democratic movements institutions
and cultures the study of anti-semitism
is not a parochial Jewish concern it is
key to understanding what threatens the
health of democratic and egalitarian
movements the theorists of a new
anti-semitism have argued that hostility
to Israel may be anti-semitic in its
motivation or in its form or in its
disproportionate quantity or intensity
or in its effect each of these
suggestions requires distinct analyses
and they make interrelate back on each
other in unexpected ways this is a study
of a phenomenon whose very existence is
angrily contested the books discussion
of the struggles over defining
anti-semitism for example is itself also
a case study of the material in question
the book is critical of those analyses
which begin with conceptual blueprints
attempting to demonstrate from argument
alone what is racist and what is
anti-semitic rather it begins with
empirical study of social movements of
debate of discussion of campaigns and of
discourse it is concerned with how
concepts arise are they actual eyes and
how they circulate between anti-semitic
and also anti-racist spaces there is a
quote from moist pus stone I think which
really encapsulates the problem that we
might well be worried about moistu says
anti-semitism can appear to be anti
hegemonic
this is the reason why a century ago
August Babel characterized it as the
socialism of fools given its subsequent
development it could also have been
called the answer imperialism of fools
as a fetish highest form of oppositional
consciousness it is particularly
dangerous because it appears to be anti
hegemonic the expression of a movement
of the little people against an
intangible global form of domination it
is a it is as a fetishized profoundly
reactionary form of anti capitalism that
I would like to begin discussing the
recent surge of modern anti-semitism in
the Arab world says moist puffs tone the
measure of the real contemporary threat
of anti-semitism is more than the sum of
its various practical and immediate
threats the real threat is the
mainstreaming and normalization of
anti-semitic politics in ways which are
as yet difficult precisely to predict
Britain Europe and America may be
approaching periods of significant and
dangerous insecurity and turmoil the key
elements of democracy itself are under
assault from a number of different
directions the distinct and opposing
critiques of democracy have more in
common with each other than their
apparently distinct proponents are
sometimes aware of the far left the
radical intellectuals the anti-semites
the xenophobic and Islamophobic of right
the radical Islamists the trumpets the
burette suitors share a number of
perspectives they have a tendency to
embrace discourses in which contempt for
democratic states cultures contempt for
liberals or contempt for neo liberals
contempt for the liberty and equality of
human beings of key elements profound
suspicions of international cooperation
and
oceans is on the rise skepticism extends
to the rule of law to science to
knowledge to international trade to the
very idea of the market it is now common
to encounter those who believe that
these elements are mere facades which
hide the old power structures in order
to subordinate the money to the few it
is not yet clear how anti-semitism might
play out in the coming years but the
emotional appeal of the populist
movements requires enemies enemies which
are to be found at the center of
dangerous global and powerful
conspiracies anti-semitism has never
been just an isolated eccentricity it
has always also been an indicator of a
profound political sickness to tolerate
this as a symptom and to miss the fatal
disease which causes it may prove to be
an error thank you
our second paper will be beyond denial
historic ala cost distortion in the
service of a new national thank you I
want to begin with looking back to
November 1st 2005 when the United
Nations General Assembly adopted a
resolution which resolves that the
United Nations will designate 27 January
as an international international day of
commemoration of memory of the victims
of the Holocaust the resolution
formalized the process that had begun to
crystallize in 2000 the year that
Swedish Prime Minister garner shot it
could be in the Stockholm forum on the
Holocaust the forum which was attended
by high-ranking senior officials and an
invited experts in 46 countries adopted
a statement known as the Stockholm
declaration which included quote a
commitment to commemorate the victims of
the Holocaust and to honor those who
stood against it the forum led to the
creation of the International taskforce
on Holocaust education research and
remembrance which in 2013 was renamed
the international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance and now consists of 31 member
nations full disclosure I was one of the
experts who participated in the
Stockholm forum and I have been involved
that remember the official US delegation
ever since and I'm also heavily involved
at the OSCE level whereas formerly a
member of the panel of experts on
freedom of religion and belief so my
presentation here today will also be
informed through my direct observation
of participation in some of those
activities
the Stockholm Foreman's declaration were
part of a movement that has led to a
once scholar is called the rapid growth
and ritualized days of remembrance or
more precisely an increase in Holocaust
commemoration days after 2000 many of
which are held in 27 January these
commemorations become a focal point of
the public calendar particularly in
Europe which with observances usually
centered around high-level political
participation the presence of survivors
and official Jewish community
representatives senior religious figures
product representatives of civil society
pilgrimages to memorial sites and major
media coverage the January 27th
commemorations have become an extremely
important moment of civic performance in
Europe creating a moment in which
combine the European countries together
in celebration of shared values that
transcend individual national
CERN's as one scholar has written that
the there's a fundamental these
fundamental ties are based upon quote a
general agreement that the murder of six
million Jews should turn into a common
memory in which the values of civil
society who built and minorities will be
protected as a fundamental European
commitments and orientation however we
are now seeing a disturbing trend where
those values are now under attack by
those who want to shift to what the way
from liberal values to what Hungarian
Prime Minister Viktor Orban has
proclaimed to be the new a liberal state
and which has penetrated to government
circles and halls of path we're in
countries that we define as Western
democracies and since those liberal
values are explicitly identified as
stemming from the experience of the
Holocaust and since part of the
experience part of the raviga rate
reinvigorate appeals in traditional
nationalism that narrate but the
narrative the Holocaust itself has come
under attack I'm referring to recent
multiple attempts to distort the history
of the Holocaust by whitewashing local
collaborators or minimizing or even
removing the Jewish identity the victims
often this is connected to a political
agenda that is concerned with creating a
traditionalist national narrative that
wants to look back to an idealized past
for heroes and models and since many of
these societies that have emerged from
both Nazi and communist occupation and
oppression the past that they glorifies
fruit' Lee in the last period of home
rule before World War two and the ideals
that they glorify can include versions
of the traditional anti-semitism that
was prevalent before the war this has
created the paradoxical situation of
increased national formal national
commemoration of the Holocaust at the
same time that the historical niro of
what is being commemorated is
increasingly under attack from a
discourse of distortion and these
attempts cannot be deemed Holocaust
denial David talked a little bit
mentioned David Irving the notorious
British Holocaust denier who lost the
famous case against the Deborah R Irving
Deborah Lipstadt in 2000 and has been
reduced to really lost all credibility
as a historian as would reduce the
pedaling guided tours the small groups
of sympathizers speaking at neo-nazi
conventions seedy halls the only place
where stream Holocaust denial is now
considered to be formally acceptable is
in for example the governments of Iran
and other similar circles the type of
Holocaust source that we are talking
about has been around ever since the end
the world war two a version of it was
official policy in many communist
countries where while the number of
victims was sometimes even exaggerated
the specific Jewish components of the
identity of the victims as a focus of
Nazi policy was erased that a
politically motivated rendering of all
the VIS all the victims as generic
victims of fascism perhaps most famously
in the original plaque at babi yar in
Kiev they referred only again to the
generic victims of fascism and this
situation led to ingenuitive Tishchenko
famous poem which highlighted the issue
the use of historians to buttress
nationalist ideology is not new Richard
Evans already writing in 1997 in his
book in defense of history pointed out
that quote nationalist historians have
quickly argued that they own the past of
their own country and that foreigners
have no business to try to appropriated
the danger that we face today was summed
up by Timothy Snyder and the concise
formulation that quote post truth is pre
fascism perhaps in no country today's
the situation were acute than in Poland
they are the most egregious examples the
attempt to criminalize Holocaust
research and even the memoirs of
Holocaust survival survivors through
proposed new law that builds on an
already existing law just to give you an
idea part of the law reads whoever
publicly claims contrary to the
historical facts the Polish nation of
the Polish states responsibility or
partial responsibility for the Nazi
crimes committed by the German third
right shall be liable to a fine or
imprisonment for up to three years and
this should apply to Polish city as sins
and to aliens
wherever thus according to the law since
Pole was occupied by Nazi Germany during
the time of the Holocaust any person who
makes a statement that refers to Polish
collaboration or complicity in the
murder of millions of Jews killed on
polish soil is potentially committing a
crime it's not totally a new initiative
as Poland's already trying to move
against the eminent Princeton historian
yan gross gross who previously received
the Polish Order of Merit in 1996 is the
author of the book neighbors which tells
of the 2001 which tells of the murder of
several hundred Jews
the town of get wobbly by their polish
neighbors in July 10th 1941 the book was
a National Book Award finalist that has
been highly acclaimed cause the major
controversy in Poland words findings
were hotly debated but did lead at least
two presidents of Poland to apologize
what happened yet Wahb made in an
interview with the german paper in 2015
gross that stated in his opinion polls
murdered more Jews than they had killed
Germans and a statement that is
supported by many leading experts but is
obviously highly controversial in Poland
this led to his being investigated with
the charge of labelling the Polish
nation because it's inside of a visit to
Poland hauled in for five hours of
questioning and the threat continues
hanging over him indeed the first
prosecutor accused science in the case
recommended dropping it was overruled by
superior in what appears to be a
political decision this was made clear
by the statement of the government's
newly appointed president of the
Institute of national remembrance which
was in charge of Holocaust memory in
Poland who said told the parliamentary
committee that it was Nazis not poles
who killed roughly 300 Jews in yet wahby
this kept directly contradicted a formal
2002 finding by his own initiative and
in this he was only following the path
laid out by an August 16 press
conference by Poland's Minister of
Justice who said quote it is not our
mother's nor our fathers who are
responsible for the crimes of the
Holocaust caused by German and Nazi
criminals in occupied Poland our duties
defend the truth and dignity the Polish
state and the Polish nation and our
fathers and mothers and our grandfathers
nothing in there about finding out what
happened nor of the victims grouse is
not really the focal points here as an
esteemed scholar in Poland in Princeton
he will not suffer from the attempted
censorship of been booming in history
another highly respected scholar young
Grabovski at the University of Ottawa
was also published on Polish involvement
of the finding and killing Jews during
the Holocaust has also been under attack
this time for the Polish Embassy itself
in Ottawa details there the full impact
of the law itself can be found in its
chilling effect on less established and
younger scholars who may fear to speak
openly on their findings I would be
dissuaded to me beginning to research
the subject of Poland in the Holocaust
this is clearly an attempt to legislate
history
in a place where governments really
should not venture those of us who have
worked with Holocaust survivors note a
certain point in any testimony will come
the line that worse than the Germans
worthy blank which refers to the local
collaborators and this is clearly um it
is not a unique sentiment and it makes
sense because these are the groups who
felt the sting of personal relationships
fatally betrayed but recounted their
emotions and experiences and now under
this new proposed law potentially facing
criminal charges at the late stage of
their life in my capacity with the IHRA
I was asked to participate with three
others in a high-level mission to Warsaw
last December to discuss the IHRA s
great concern of the proposed laws which
directly contradict the Stockholm
declaration which Poland had signed on
to indeed I was told directly there that
the poles were very upset to see the
usage of the term polish death camps
still appear in the West and were
terming determined to try to wipe it out
they had felt that since education had
failed they had a resort to legal
recourse on this this was puzzling
because IHRA most responsible Holocaust
related institutions and scholars shared
Poland's feeling about the inaccuracy
inappropriate us of that term indeed I
had been nerdstrom Ethel my own
institution removing it from our website
a decade ago and at last spring's ihr a
plenary introduced a statement that IRA
should go on record opposing quote
Athiya starkly unsupported ly use of the
term polish death camps which was
officially adopted by the organization
so while there seems to be consensus in
the expert community on that Polish have
a case on that they has seemed to be
blind to the success of their campaign
and are persisting with illegal efforts
[Music]
last spring the newly appointed director
the Polish state tourist organization
decided to drop outfits and the Polish
Poland Jewish Museum in Warsaw from the
agency's promotions claiming that he
wanted emphasize the promotion of Polish
monuments culture and music and clearly
ash wits and the Jewish Museum did not
qualify under his ideas he was quoted as
saying I do not need to expose places
and events related to the history of
other nations making it
listen even though he aspired for this
action it is important as I said to note
that he clearly sees Jews as distinct
for the Polish nation the 150 million
dollar new museum of the Second World
War in Gdansk has also become mired in
controversy Timothy Snyder for example
has been heavily involved with that the
museum's original director was not the
only person I'm sorry the museum last
spring had their original director fired
and replaced with someone Moore's the
tombs of the government's line that
according to Yaroslav Kachinsky the head
of the Polish ruling party pis who
explicitly condemned the museum as a
tool of German propaganda stating it as
a museum which subscribes to the German
historic policy another historian one of
the people that were met with him I
visit to Warsaw said we should do
something like what the Jewish community
has done which managed to arrange the
Holika around the Holocaust all the
other events of World War two the Jewish
community has succeeded in making the
Holocaust according to him the dominant
narrative of World War two to the
exclusion of everything against the
museum's original directors not the only
a person who lost their job to this
ideological purge director Poland's
Information Center in Berlin was fired
last spring because she was giving quote
too much attention to Jewish subjects
among them what the Poland's Culture
Minister had said included the promotion
of a culture of shame over the Holocaust
and a few weeks ago report from Poland
indicated that the Polish Ministry of
Education was dropping the study of
Auschwitz for the state curriculum after
the story broke with the face of strong
public criticism for the director the
Auschwitz State Museum and others ash
wits was restored almost immediately to
the curriculum so Poland is perhaps well
is perhaps the most acute case there are
other cases involved as well when Viktor
orbán was reelected his second term as
prime minister of Hungary his platform
included steering Hungary to a more
conservative nationalist direction he
spoke openly about it as I said quoting
tried to develop a new state that we
were building on a liberal state a non
liberal state and a year later he
followed that up with another speech
where he talked about regaining the
dominance
not only in Hungary but throughout
Europe of the National Christian idea
as the former Yale historian an
invaluable blogger a favela has pointed
out in her blog Hungarian spectrum the
Christian national ideals the dominant
ideology of the horthy Nazi era and
reflected the anti-semitism of the
horthy regime the actual process of
restoring the luster to this ideology
began to take shape in the form of a
preamble to the new constitution of
Hungary that was adopted in April 2011
and that basically says that Hungary
does not have any responsibility for any
action that occur between the Nazi
occupation of Hungary night scene 44 and
until the the end of the russian of the
Communist era in 1990 during this period
was exactly late 1944 was the period of
the mass deportation of Hungarian Jews
when over 400,000 Jews were deported in
murder in Auschwitz this effort was
described by Randolph Graham the
preeminence scholar of the Holocaust in
Hungary that the Orban government is
trying to pursue two major objectives to
establish a historical continuity
between the Hungarian state of the
horthy era and the Hungarian state of
the post-communist period is the first
and to convince the world that hungry
had lost its sovereignty in the wake of
the beginning of the German occupation
and was the victim itself not
responsible for the subsequent
destruction of the Jews the reality is
Amman is quite different Bram points out
there approximately 200,000 Hungarian
collaborators whose enthusiam and
efficiency you were so recognized that
the SS that edifies men could write the
Hungarians must surely be the Senate
from the Huns it's nowhere else has he
seen so much brutality and in 2014 orbit
proceeded to make this religious
approach highly visible he ordered a new
memorial to be built to commemorate the
70th anniversary of the 1944 German
occupation of Hungary the memorial
showed the predatory eagle symbol of
Imperial Germany swooping down upon the
Archangel Gabriel representing Hungary
thus portraying Hungary as it helpless
an innocent victim of Nazi aggression in
2012 Vulgarian government proposed the
insertion into national curriculum of
four anti-semitic writers leading the
Jewish community to publicly say they
were shocked by the fact and then the
school curriculum mayor put foots being
put forth such authors who are being
bounded by their obvious anti submitted
view
funded by their obviously at estimate
abuse and 2012 vulgarians attempted to
ribery one of these writers remains in
it were romanian town and a ceremony
that included the speaker then garyun
parliament the hungarian state secretary
for culture the Romanians protested
which led to a diplomatic issue one of
the writers involved Albert vos has
become extremely popular in Hungary a
quota table below and by 2012 vos was
the his books were in Transylvania more
popular than the Bible he had written
one of his most famous works and
controversial was called rats conquest a
fable for young hungarians which was
published in the deportation of 18,000
jews from Cluj and has since been posted
on storm front pictures the most popular
neo-nazi website and taken down in the
wake of charlottesville and on other
neo-nazi websites in the US and in
Hungary the inclusion of vos prompted
the survivor and Nobel Peace Prize
winner Elie Wiesel to write a letter
which returned his granddaughter the
Hungarian Cross of Merit in 2004 the
Hungarian government complaining of
attempts to rehabilitate Vasa other
figures of collaboratively with
Hungarian fascist regime a couple years
ago a series of readings and
commemorations were held in
quasi-official Hungarian houses in New
York and Los Angeles to commemorate boss
his life and his works when I protest
the Hungarian consulate in New York I
was thought that there was no connection
between the Consul and the Hungarian
houses so I asked them to publicly
condemn the event and distance
themselves from it we had exchange of
communications but the Consul General
refused to move from his position and
quoting at the same time we must observe
the sensitivity of those who respect the
literature and patriotism of Albert vos
other examples abound they include a
statement by the director of the
government-sponsored Veritas Historical
Institute that the explosion of Jews in
the summer of 1941 to kamenets-podolsk
ear over 20,000 were murdered was just a
quote immigration action widespread
criticism ensued but the politically
connected directors apologized as
lowness position is interesting in light
of Hungary's vehement anti immigration
policy and the vilification of refugees
to point out that
his comment could be read as
legitimizing deportation of refugees
that leads directly to their murder
perhaps the most problematic was the
proposal to build a new Holocaust Museum
in Budapest to replace one which already
exists in a former synagogue the plan
was conceived as a centerpiece of a
large-scale government propaganda
project that was focused on the 2014
commemoration of the 70th anniversary of
the deportation and in 2015 to continue
on the activities and arrests of rural
volunteer the strong government backing
translated to government control and the
historian Maria Schmidt was named - as
the project director on the surface she
had strong credentials of including
being known as or bonds chief ideologue
she's a director the house of terror
museum that deals with the history of
the communist secret police as perhaps
the best support and most popular museum
in Budapest our academic training
features a specialty in Jewish Studies
and scoot stints as a researcher or
visiting professor Berlin Technical
University Center for anti-semitism
studies tel University Oxford Indiana
University's Jewish Studies programs and
Yad Vashem however from the beginning
the plan was highly controversial
writings left her vulnerable to charges
of anti-semitism and Holocaust
revisionism for example including
writing that the Nuremberg trials and
similar war crime trials were political
trials that serve political purposes in
the effort brought alien elements of the
jurisdictional system she also had no
plans what I met with her and asked to
see the plans of the proposed Museum she
showed a few architectural drawings and
that was it all sorts of issues arose
with it which finally these three things
they museum itself the statue and the
the very test Institute led the Jewish
community to officially boycott all the
Hungarian government commemorations
which was highly embarrassing to the
Hungarians because among other things
they were planning on taking the chair
of the ihr a during this period - 2015
to commemorate the events without the
Jewish community was an international
black eye which included the involvement
of the United States State Department
getting involved and international
organizations such as ihr a and finally
LED for example - a statement by
President Obama in January 27th
in commemoration at the Israeli embassy
in Washington where he said that just go
straight to his statement last year a
group of hungry a group in Hungary
received government funds and he's
referring to another proposal which is
to build a statue to not only horthy
there's a such a horsey cult of statues
that sehe has an entry in his Wikipedia
page on this hoarsely cult but also
statutes to other World War 2 era
collaborators including one named
balance Holman who was a historian who
basically introduced the Hungarian
version of the Nuremberg Laws to Hungary
which stripped Jews of their rights and
citizenship ultimately leading to their
deportation the attempt to rehabilitate
Holman led to a proposal to build a
statue in his honor to place in his
honor and I together with the special
envoy and anti-semitism I was deeply
involved in those efforts to protest it
we had a conference that we organized
with a Hungarian NGO in December right
before the statue was supposed to be
built the afternoon after the conference
port Orban went into Parliament and made
a statement that he would not support
any more financially give them a funding
or backing to build any more statues of
anyone who collaborated with the Nazis
in any way including horthy and Hamad
however President Obama made the
statements saying last year a group and
Hungary received government funds to
build a statue in honor of balanced home
on a Nazi supporter and proponent of
anti-jewish laws who called for
deportation of Jews in 1944 the United
States worked with many Hungarians and
other interested international groups
very hard to prevent direction of the
statute so we see in a sense two
contrasting models in Poland where the
government the transience has continued
and in Hungary where in the affect of
both local pressure from the Jewish
community international support and
high-level diplomatic intervention
particularly for the United States there
have been some successes in rolling back
some of the initiatives to give an
example of how these two models fall out
there are two other countries I'll just
briefly refer to one Croatia which is
more in the Hungarian model in which
there were
Hisashi slogans in front of the statue
of the local collaborators and there
were slogans at front of the cinah botch
the concentration camp death camp in in
in Croatia which were just removed under
process they have to be international
protests and local Jewish protest the
Jewish community has boycotted the
official government commemoration events
they are the last two years similar the
Hungarian boycott a Minister of Interior
who was overseeing a sent about you I do
stashies sympathies was sacked after six
months and was replaced and so there
have been some progress and part of it
was based again on a recent visit by the
current US special envoy on the
Holocaust issues to Croatia just a
couple of months ago where he brought up
these issues contrast that with Ukraine
which has similar to to Poland has a law
on the books that basically forbids the
shaming of the Ukrainian national
movements of the oun to the yo-yo and B
which was the Bandera LED native
insurgents and partisans who are also
responsible for the killing and ethnic
cleansing of tens of thousands and Jews
of hundreds of thousands of Poland's of
poles and at this point map law in
Hungary in the Ukraine forbids any
critical comments or research about
their their activities it is interesting
to note that there are certain
commonalities about these countries and
the way they fall out they share in many
cases are relatively friendly stance
toward Israel motivate in part least by
their anti Muslim anti-terrorism
policies they share official of support
for Holocaust commemoration three of the
countries are members of the ihr a
Ukraine is not a member but it's been
moving tentatively toward membership
they share an extreme nationalist
historical discourse that is used to try
and undermine historical narrative of
the Holocaust for political purposes
this is crystallized through a synergy
of historians and politicians who feed
off each other they frequently resort to
stereotypes particularly of Jews
exemplified most prominently in the
campaign against George Soros for
example and they have a somewhat elastic
approach the freedom of speech issues
which is
different from the way we conceived of
it there of course differences as well
as I mentioned in Hungary in Croatian
local Jewish communities felt reasonable
feel reasonably secure and safe and were
able to protest more than in Ukraine and
Poland which now feel more more
threatened and finally if as I mentioned
the importance of foreign opinion and in
this case and here I'm couldn't by
concluding remarks are the role of the
United States the role the US has been
pivotal in forcing change an engagement
upon these issues however that is now
all in question with with a roll back
from foreign aid and participation that
has been posed by the by the Trump
administration and the administration
itself has had difficulties on these
issues witnessed Trump's original
January 27th statements about the
Holocaust which emitted any mention of
the word Jews not to mention is
inadvertent perhaps remarks of his press
secretary who doubted that Hitler used
any sort of chemical means to to kill
Jews and as well as Trump's visit to
Warsaw where he did not breaking
tradition did not visit any of the
Holocaust related sites spoke in a
square that was associated nationalist
ideas and Peres did some of the ideas
and themes of the nationalist government
which was noted by commentators both
Jewish and non-jewish in Warsaw now
there are some reports and Polish press
for example that parts of his speech
were written by Sebastian's worship
other reports have it that they were
written by contributed by a colleague of
Gorka in the US regard to Gorka I'm just
gonna say very briefly the issue to me
was not Gorkhas membership in this
obscure group
the issue was Gorkhas participation or
people that he magazines that he
contributed to that were edited by
Holocaust deniers and anti-semites the
circles that he traveled them that he
has never disavowed Gorga's defense
comes back to us we've heard earlier
that a is so pro-israel he must be
attacked whether and there's a quote
whether it's the President or Steve
banner or student Steve Miller or myself
however Gorka was also the major
defender of the January 27th remarks
calling any criticism of them asinine
this is reflective in the approach that
has been popularized by Bannon which was
returned to nationalism Bannon took the
America first isolationist idea that was
used as a slogan by Trump and basically
put it in the context of an ideological
platform related to some of the people
that we heard earlier spoke about
earlier julissa bola reneged and young
and so on the question now with Bannon
and Gorkhas firing is where exactly is
the administration going to be going in
the future and we have talked about many
of us had this sort of monochromatic
vision that it was the problem was only
in the white house the reality is for
example that the white house was more
interested in appointing an advisor on
the special advisor or not envoy and
anti-semitism and the blockage was at
the State Department in Secretary of
State tiller Sims views who initially
wanted to get rid of that office so
we're left in a situation where we have
an extremely chaotic administrator
administration that's unclear on what
their future is going to be in the
direction that it's going to go with the
removal of Ganon and Gorga and we are
left with what as as Timothy Snyder's
pointed out the use of Holocaust with
political propaganda leads to the
question of without history numbers
become public which it's the same
instrument in the international
competition for martyrdom such reasoning
allows the Nationalists to hug himself
with one arm and strike his neighbor
with the other he adds unfortunately
claiming victim status is not itself
brain sound ethical choices and an era
after Charlottesville where things seem
to have changed dramatically perhaps the
best thing that we could say is going
back to a previous inhabitant of the
Oval Office and to remember the sign
that used to hang over the desk of Harry
Truman which was the buck stops here
[Music]